Speaker 1: under oath. Fox News propagandist
Sean HANNITY admits he doesn't believe Donald
Trump's fraud claims about 2020, and yet he widely
promoted them and hosted guests uncritically who
also promoted those very same sorts of claims. A
very interesting article from The New York Times.
In testimony, HANNITY and other Fox employees
said they doubted Trump's fraud claims. Wednesday,
Lawyers for Dominion Voting Systems shared some of
the strongest evidence yet that some Fox employees
knew what they broadcast about the claims was
false. The articles by Jeremy Peters. We will
link to it in the description to the YouTube
video. November 30th, shorn of 2020, Sean
HANNITY hosted Sidney Powell on his show, as she
had in many other interviews. Fox and elsewhere,
she spun wild conspiracy theories about what
she said was corruption all across the country,
in countless districts, in a plot to steal
reelection from the president, Donald Trump.
At the center of the plot were machines from
Dominion voting systems, which Powell claimed
ran an algorithm. Sometimes they called it
a logarithm that switched votes from Trump
to Biden. HANNITY interrupted her with a gentle
question that had been circulating among election
deniers. Despite a lack of supporting proof.
Why were Democrats silencing whistleblowers
who could prove the fraud? Did HANNITY believe
any of this quote? I did not believe it for 1/2.
Now, if you watched Hannity's TV show, you
wouldn't have heard him say that. HANNITY
gave that answer under oath in a deposition
in Dominion's $1.6 billion defamation lawsuit
against Fox News, according to info disclosed
yesterday. Hannity's disclosure, along with others
that emerged about what Fox News executives and
hosts really believed became one of the loudest
megaphones for a lie as their network became
one of the loudest megaphones for lies about the
election. This is the strongest evidence yet that
Fox employees knew what they were broadcasting was
false. This is not a shock. This is not a shock.
HANNITY is an amoral propagandist profiteer,
no doubt about it. But he is not so stupid
that he believe this nonsense. And in fact,
the totality of the text messages that we now know
Sean HANNITY sent to people like Mark Meadows and
others, and this deposition under oath tells us
they were knowingly spreading misinformation. It
doesn't make it any better. Okay. If you thought
HANNITY was that stupid, he's not that stupid.
But it tells us he knew he was spreading lies.
It's almost an even worse case for them. They
weren't just gullible idiots. They were knowingly
spreading lies and disinformation. And of course,
we know that when push comes to shove, they go for
it's not news, it's entertainment. Tucker Carlson,
FOX News lawyer, said Tucker Carlson is an
entertainer. It's not news. The things he says
are laced with hyperbole and exaggeration and
titillating language. They're not to believe,
be believed literally, but in reality it's
not even really entertainment because it's
not entertaining. It's sort of B.S. and lies. It's
a B.S. factory that they pump out, not just for
profit. Yes, profit is part of it, but it's also
to maintain access to people in power. HANNITY We
now know had a relationship with Trump to the
extent that Trump has friends. And for Trump,
a friend means someone who's useful to me until
they turn against me. Okay, fine. But that's the
definition. HANNITY would hang out with Trump. He
would be on Trump's plane and all this different
stuff. It was to maintain access as much as it
was for profitability. Now, in a well-functioning,
educated democracy, where people are educated in
media literacy, etc., people like HANNITY wouldn't
have careers. Not because they're kicked off of
the air. I'm not suggesting anyone kick them off
the air. But I'm saying no one would watch it.
If we had an educated, informed Democracy Now!
Ultimately, I really don't care if they claim
now to have privately doubted the things Trump
was spreading. They publicly supported it,
and they are part of why there was a public
willing to go and do what they did on January
6th. Will there be any consequences for this?
Probably not tomorrow. Friday is the day one day
membership special last discount of the year.
Last opportunity to participate in the membership
special for the year. Your first month payment is
going to be donated and doubled. We are working
with the charity who I will name tomorrow because
they told us it's a problem for them if we name
them in advance. We're entering into a marketing
agreement and it can be a problem for them as a
five or one C3. But many of you I know know which
charity it is. One of the most effective ways to
actually help people around the world is to give
them cash. Something like 98% of donated funds
get to people when you just send them cash and
let them figure out what they need. So tomorrow,
if you're on my mailing list, you're going to get
an email and it's going to tell you how to sign
up at a discount. Your first month's payment,
we're going to donate and then we're going
to double it up to the first $15,000. Really
great opportunity to both get a membership.
Help us by getting access to the bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: And we are helping other people.
So get on my mailing list at David Pakman dot
com tomorrow morning, maybe late morning, maybe
early afternoon, you'll get an email telling you
how to avail yourself of this fantastic special.